[Music]
well I think any cook loves to hear
that's delicious but it means a lot more
when the food is actually horrific it's
a dead body it's a lung maybe a roadkill
rats
[Music]
I'm Janice poon and I'm the food stylist
you come to if you want a Grizzly a
little something for your table what
have I had done roasted legs Peking
style whole bodies edible insects tiny
organs for dead rats edible snails oh
space whales raw of course
Jonas can cook up a mean severed head
but she's pretty much a jack of all
trades just how many jobs have you had
Janice first I was an art director in an
agency then I'll caterer a cookbook
author a graphic novelist a sculptor
then a miniaturist couturier and uh
writing did I forget anything
now back to the juicy stuff oh I love
the Reading part of the creative process
lay back on the sofa I read as much as
possible I just do a quick sketch to
communicate to everybody the look I'm
going for and narrow the field the
kitchen is really where the sorrow
begins that's where everything that you
thought was going to work out great
doesn't and that is where you really
start to think well now what am I going
to do
no it's kind of yummy
nothing like a little right hamburger to
get going
hang on did she just eat raw meat
as a food stylist I get all kinds of
requests from actors who have dietary
restrictions I didn't expect however to
get one from a vampire queen who
wouldn't eat meat what I used was
essentially sweet potato that doesn't
look like meat hmm
maybe I need something to make it more
gummy I'll put a bunch of glutinous
flour in well that's a bit yellow for
meat isn't it so I'll put in some beets
after a couple minutes of the microwave
spinning around what it needs is a
little tiny Flex of fat I use chopped up
rice and just plow that stuff in oil and
that's really going to make it look
visceral
surely that's not edible
it's not just edible it's delicious
any more tips and tricks
well one little food item that we have
and a lot of horror movies is um corn
syrup corn syrup with food coloring in
it to make it look like blood
a buckets and buckets and buckets of
this stuff get used for TV shows and you
just like pour it on and lick it off
I would say the duct tape of food
styling is oil because a little slick of
oil is going to make anything look as if
it just freshly cooked or it's just
Juicy and Delicious
well fake mold if you want it to be
edible you have to use Dutch processed
cocoa which is a black powder spirulina
powder icing sugar and white food
coloring you can dust them on your food
and it'll look just like mold furry but
yummy
sometimes I use toothpaste because it
comes in a tube and you just throw it in
their bag and
and that's little Blobs of mold but
people don't like to eat a lot of
toothpaste so there you go
some of Jonas's most gruesome dishes
feature in the tv show Hannibal
when I looked at the first Hannibal
script I thought wow these people are
crazy mads was the most adventurous he
was kind of annoyed with me the first
day when I didn't serve up real long
real brain and real liver but then I
knew he was going to be an adventurous
eater so it all cut loose from there
our final scene was to be bedelia's
dining on her own leg the leg was the
old go-to pork it had a marrow bone at
the thiant and a lamb shank at the ankle
end I felta had to apologize to Jillian
and I said Jillian I'm sorry I made the
leg so big if I had made it the size of
your leg it wouldn't have looked as
impressive she did say oh that's
beautiful which is what you really want
she didn't say oh my leg looks good
[Laughter]
any final words of wisdom Janice part of
Storytelling of course is that tension
especially with horror where so many of
the characters are psychically there on
a knife's edge you want your food to be
on a knife's edge too you wanted to
Teeter is it horrible is it delicious no
it's horrible and delicious
foreign